In this sequence of segments,
we review some mathematical
background that will be
useful at various
places in this course.
Most of what is covered, with
the exception of the last
segment, is material that you
may have seen before.
But this could still be an
opportunity to refresh some of
these concepts.
I should say that
this is intended
to be just a refresher.
Our coverage is not going to
be complete in any sense.
What we will talk about is
sets, various definitions
related to sets, and some basic
properties, including De
Morgan's laws.
We will talk about what a
sequence is and what it means
for a sequence to converge
to something.
We will talk about
infinite series.
And as an example, we will look
at the geometric series.
Then we will talk about some
subtleties that arise when you
have sums of terms that are
indexed with multiple indices.
And finally, probably the most
sophisticated part, will be a
discussion of countable versus
uncountable sets.
Countable sets are like
the integers.
Uncountable sets are
like the real line.
And they're fundamentally
different.
And this fundamental difference
reflects itself
into fundamentally different
probabilistic models--
models that involve discrete
experiments and outcomes
versus models that involve
continuous outcomes.